think if you're not ready to be a mother  maybe you should take steps to have  precautions before you have sex yeah of  course I'm saying it it seems like women  aren't doing that because 40 of women  have had two or more abortions that get  abortion 60 that get them in the future  so you don't actually know what person  so sorry refresh me on the statement  that you made originally because I had  to go up from it from the abortion as a  cop-out that's the original no no no no  from the little statement that you just  made now say for example a woman makes  it not necessarily a mistake but she  gets end up getting pregnant and she's  not in a position that she wants to be a  mother do you feel that she doesn't have  the right to make a decision to be a  mother or not I would say no when you  get pregnant it's a unique DNA sequence  that's different from the mother and the  father if we're going to believe the  science 95 of scientists say that life  begins at conception